Oh, welcome church.
It's great to see you.
Uh, last Sunday I had the privilege
of sitting right back there and, uh, watching
and getting to participate in Brandon.
So aptly leading us through this series we've been walking
through in Second Samuel, I'm so thankful for
what God's done in his life
and in what God is going to do in Him and through him.
Uh, but I'm excited to be back up here
as we continue this search for God's promised King
in this Old Testament book.
As we get into it today, I wanna ask you a question first.
Have you ever faced a seemingly impossible situation?
Now, I don't mean like, you know, traffic on the way
to work in the morning or something like that's impossible.
No, not that. I'm talking about something
that really is overwhelming.
We got dozens of examples in our lives.
You could think of things like a job loss
or uh, maybe family that's just falling apart around you
or a cancer diagnosis.
You know, these kind of things that just feel
like this is impossible.
There's no way out. Well,
there's a scene in two Chronicles 20 where King Jehosaphat,
which I don't know why anybody doesn't name
their kid Jehosaphat anymore.
But anyway, uh, king Jehosaphat,
he received horrifying news
that this massive enemy army was coming against Judah
and they were about 15 miles away.
And you can imagine what's going through his head
as his life and the entire kingdom were at risk
of just getting wiped off the face of the earth.
Yet instead of running away
or hiding in fear, what did he do?
He led his people to fast
and pray, to sing,
to praise the Lord in the face of this enemy army coming.
And what did God do? Well, God
cause the enemy army to turn on itself
and basically destroy themselves to
where the scripture says there was not
one of them left alive.
Now, now, what Jehosaphat did takes a measure of trust.
Doesn't it like trust the Lord, trust
that you're in the right, you're on his side.
Like just trust the Lord, trust God's plan for his people.
Trust the whole promise thing of like you had to trust God
to do what Jehosaphat did.
Is that how you respond when you feel surrounded
is my first instinct in the face
of abject terror That's coming my way,
is my first instinct to worship.
Well, as we look back to David's early life,
that was his response.
Remember, we love the David and Goliath story.
Why did David know that Goliath was gonna be defeated?
Because David could look back at God defeated this enemy
and that animal and these things and God had worked
and David trusted God
and God knew David knew
that God was gonna come through again.
Why would he not? Right? This is, this is
what David leaned on.
His trust in God led him to this defeat of a giant.
Yet over the last few weeks, we've seen David's trust begin
to drift and it got him in a whole heap of trouble
as he started abating responsibilities as he started
to get in this place of sin and and dominating his life
and all the effects of that, his trust
that he had when he was a young man did not follow through
as he became the king.
Well, if you remember what Brandon shared last week in
chapters 15 and 16, God in his grace
and mercy sent David back to the wilderness
because in first Samuel, the wilderness was
where David learned how to trust God.
It was where he saw Saul the king come
after him, try to take his life away
and he was forced to trust God even as he was running, even
how as he was afraid for his life he was was threatened.
And so he turned to God.
Well, the wilderness again
led David to draw back nearer to God,
which led to his trust growing again.
As we'll see in the passage today as that shows up
as David's son Absalom taking, trying
to take the throne away from David and, and,
and there seemed to be no way out.
David's in the middle of the wilderness,
he's at the risk of his life.
It seems like it's resetting from one Samuel.
All of that looks like there's no way out. God made a way.
David trusted God to make a way
and it was God who delivered David.
It was God who protected David.
It was God who never left David in the middle of
what he needed in spite of David's sin against God.
All of that God had a plan for David's life and
and David trusted him.
And what we need to learn today is that
that truth applies not only for David back then it applies
for God's children by faith today that you
and I can trust him just as much as David did.
He's the same God. We can trust him.
We can walk in that same assurance.
That's what we're gonna see today in chapter 17
and 18 of two Samuel.
So if you're not there yet, go ahead
and turn there with me two Samuel 17 and 18.
That's where we're gonna be today
as your attorney, lemme pray for us.
Lord, I pray just humbly
that this is your word.
This is meant for us. It's not just old stories.
This is something that you want to use living an active
to cut deeper than any two edges sword into our souls
that you would expose our hearts where we need it,
convict us where we need it,
but also God encourage us,
give us assurance where we need it.
And for those facing insurmountable impossible situations,
they would see that it's you who fight the battle.
It's you who make the way out,
especially eternally.
Thank you. God help us Holy Spirit, speak
through your word today.
In Jesus' name, amen.
So again, at this point in the narrative
we see that David's on the run.
Absalom is the one who's chasing him trying
to take over the throne and
and again all of this is part of the fulfillment of
what Nathan prophesied to David.
After David's sin, Nathan said, Hey,
your family's gonna fall apart.
It's gonna be strife and
there's gonna be sword never leaving.
All of this is evidence that that's coming true.
Well watch what happens next as Absalom determines what
to do, David's on the run Absalom's trying to figure out
what he's doing next.
And so AB Absalom determines this.
Look at verses one through four.
Moreover, a hitha fell said to Absalom,
let me choose 12,000 men and I will arise
and pursue David tonight.
I will come upon him while he was weary and discouraged
and throw him into a panic.
And all the people who are with him will flee.
I'll strike down only the king
and I'll bring all the people back to you.
As a bride comes home to her husband.
You seek the life of only one man
and all the people will be at peace.
And the advice seemed right in the eyes of Absalom
and all the elders of Israel.
Now let's just remember who these people are.
Ah, Hitha fell. We saw this last week in chapter 16 was this
well trusted, well-respected, um, advisor to the king.
And everybody looked at him like he
spoke the very words of God.
Like that's how much he was respected.
And so here, even in this moment, he gave good advice.
Like it actually was humanly perfect.
If you're trying to take out your
enemy, this would've worked.
Go strike him while he's weary, scatter his followers.
Kill the king and bring everybody else back
as you're the one who defeated him
and they'll all follow you, right?
That's the human way to go about this. That would've worked.
But skip down to verse 14 with me real quick.
Look at what verse 14 says
about this whole scene
and Absalom and all the men of Israel said The Council
of Whoe, the Archie is better
than the Council of Hitha fell.
We'll come back to that in a second.
For the Lord had ordained to defeat the good counsel
of a hitha fell so
that the Lord might bring harm upon Absalom.
So what we see here is
that God is still fully in charge.
He he's still fully in charge.
It might have seemed like things are outta control.
It might have seemed like things were about to overrun,
enemy's about to win.
But God had a plan the whole time.
And God's plan was to bring judgment upon Absalom for all
that Absalom had done to your ser his father
with all the sin against the women
that he committed in the previous chapters.
Like all of that was God's judgment.
He's bringing judgment on Absalom.
And it's interesting how God did that.
He actually used an inferior plan also presented
to Absalom in the same scene.
He saw it hinted at a little bit.
There was this other advisor there named who Shy
and he had a plan too.
Now who was this guy? This guy was a, a man loyal to David.
In fact functioned kinda like a spy here in this scene.
But in the same moment
after everybody looked at a Hitha fell
and they were like, well that's great advice.
For some reason Absalom says,
well there's this other advisor who shy over here.
Let's invite him in and see what he has to say.
God's at work. And so what, who shy said in verses five
through 13, he gives this plan
that's actually really a bad plan comparatively
to what Hitha fell said.
Because what he said is basically,
let's not try to kill David.
David's this big warrior. We might get killed ourselves.
Let's not do that. Let's instead amass this huge army
and try to show strength against David
and his few men over here.
And maybe David will just like give up.
Like it doesn't make any sense.
But what it did in God's sovereign plan
was it allowed David enough time to get away from the scene
and go hide as they took the time to amass this great army.
It gave David time to get away.
'cause who shy after the scene, he goes
and tells David through a course.
We'll see in a second he gets David the information David
runs off Hides has time to do that
because it took a long time rather than
what HiTA fellow's plan was,
let's go tonight, let's go catch him.
Now this plan takes time
to gather all these people
and we'll see how that worked out here in a moment.
But here's the point. Let me just stop for a second.
The point of all this so far is that God sovereignly,
orchestrates defeat for the wicked.
Now we're seeing that right here.
Verse 14 was this insertion by the narrator to say,
Hey listen, here's what's actually going
on behind the scenes.
God is ordaining all this stuff to bring harm upon Absalom.
Why? Because Absalom was wicked
and needed to be judged for what he had done.
And so God is doing all of this, orchestrating all
of these things to bring defeat for the wicked.
And he did it through wild ways.
This supposedly wise counselor,
a Hitha fellow, everybody trusted him.
Everybody believed what he said.
God frustrated the plans that he gave
In order to bring about God's purposes for David.
Now, Absalon was fully responsible for choosing
who shys advice over a hitha fellows that was on him.
But again, God was ordaining the outcome
to bring David back to the throne.
Absalom didn't deserve to be there, deserved judgment.
God was working that out to bring David back.
And what does that teach us today?
See, it's really easy for us to read these stories
and think, man, that was a couple thousand years ago.
I'm not facing anything like that.
I don't have King I all this stuff, right?
How does this relate to us today?
Well, let's just think about this Christian.
When the schemes of the enemy seem flawless,
when wickedness seems unstoppable,
what we learn is that God is still at
Work.
God's still working all of this behind the scenes.
We cannot think that God is up there merely reacting
to evil plans That he was somehow surprised like, oh man,
I gotta figure out a better way.
This is something that Fel said or I should figure out.
God was already at work behind the scenes,
frustrating, defeating the plans
before they even began, right?
You don't have to worry that he's like up there trying
to figure it out and he's,
he's not really sure how it's gonna play out.
He's orchestrating defeat for those who are wicked
for the wicked in this scene.
He's saying, no, I am working all of this to bring about
what I planned.
Isn't that good news for us?
When we look at the world and it seems like evil's winning,
it seems like the plans are always against me or against us
and we don't have to worry
because God has it all in his hands.
We can take heart in the same sovereignty
that overcame Absalom's rebellion
and we can praise the same God who turned the wisdom
of this world into foolishness.
He still does it today. God's sovereignly
orchestrates defeat for the wicked.
They will not win.
Ultimately they will not win. So don't fear.
And here's one way God did that in this scene.
It's really interesting how he does
that in one specific way,
how he multiplies deliverance for David here.
See, we've just seen, of course he,
he's orchestrating defeat on one hand for the wicked,
but at the same time he's multiplying deliverance
for his people in multiple forms.
For David here in chapter 17
and 18, I wanna just walk you through really quickly
some deliverance means
that God brought about in David's life.
Watch this. There's first this network
of protection around David.
I'll show you this. Verses 15 through 22.
First you've got who shy even in the middle of this.
Then verse 15, who shy said to
and abiathar the priests, thus
and so did the Hitha fellow council
Absalom and the elders of Israel.
Thus and so have I counseled now therefore send quickly
and tell David, do not stay tonight
at the forge of the wilderness.
But by all means Passover lest the king
and all the people are with him be swallowed up.
Now Jonathan and Ahaz, by the way,
these names are really hard for me
to say too, so don't worry about it.
These are hard names they were waiting at in Rogel,
a female servant was to go and tell them and they were to go
and tell King David for they were not
to be seen entering the city.
Now just did you see that?
Like there's like 12 people somehow involved here
and you go tell him and her and she goes over here
and tells them and it's, it's this whole network of people
Watch eight verse 18.
But a young man saw them and told Absalom.
And so both of them went away quickly
and came to the house of a man at Baim
who had a well in his courtyard.
And they went down into it and the woman took
and spread a covering over the well's mouth
and scattered grain on it and nothing was known of it.
When Absalom servants came to the woman at the house,
they said, where are Ahaz?
And Jonathan and the woman said to them,
they've gone over the brook of water and when they'd sought
and could not find them, they returned to Jerusalem.
After they'd gone, the men came up outta the well and went
and told King David
and they said to David, arise, go quickly over the water
for thus and so has a helel counseled against you.
Then David arose and all the people who were with him,
they crossed the Jordan River by daybreak.
Not one was left who had not crossed the Jordan,
meaning they all got away.
So again, did you see how many people were involved
that God was ordaining, that these people talked to this guy
and they met this man who had a well
and they, they were scared
because they were at risk of their lives
and these people were coming after him.
So they hid the well and this woman covered it up
and nobody even knew it was there.
Like all of this stuff. There's just this network of people
that God has ordained.
Why to protect David so
that he would get the information he needed when he needed
it so that he could get away.
You get to the end of the chapter, the last three verses,
talk about God providing food
and supplies to David's men in the desert.
Like they didn't have any ability to take food with them.
They're on the run. God ordains these people
to bring them food and water in the
middle of the wilderness.
You see God's deliverance showing up.
It also shows up in the actual battle in chapter 18
where Absalom did amass a great army.
So he brings these thousands and thousands
and thousands of people against David to try
to defeat David, but watch how the fighting played out.
This is it down into chapter 18.
Now look at verses six through eight.
So the army went out into the field against Israel
and the battle was fought in the forest of Ephraim
and the men of Israel were defeated there
by the servants of David.
And the loss there was great on that day.
20,000 men, the battle spread over the face
of all the country and the forest devoured more people
that day than the sword.
Did you catch that? Did you see what that just said?
God himself became David's warrior
utilizing even nature to swallow up
soldiers even more than David's arm's.
Swords did. The forest did it.
God used even nature to deliver David.
Then there was Absalom himself.
How did this work out dealing with this rebel
who was trying to take the throne?
Look at verse nine. And Absalom happened
to meet the servants of David.
Absalom was riding on his mule
and the mule went under the thick branches
of a great oak tree and his head caught fast in the oak
and he was suspended between heaven
and earth while the mule that was under him went on.
Now isn't that ironic?
Remember back in chapter 14 it described in great detail
absalom's beautiful hair
That he was the picture of every shampoo commercial
you've ever seen on tv.
This was the guy, five pounds worth of hair every year.
It was the symbol of his pride and his vanity
and it was something that here got him caught
and put it a vulnerable position.
The Very thing that marked him off as strength and
and beauty and all this stuff was the very thing
that caught him in the oak tree.
Now we'll pick that back up in a second,
but I don't want us to move past this too quickly, all
that God just did for David.
Like Watch, watch this. Do you see what he did?
He used every circumstance to secure victory
for his beloved.
Just think about it. This, for some reason,
acceptance of bad advice.
Why would Absalon pick this one over that one?
It was only God ordaining this, which
by the way gave David time to get away
because David was only one mile away from this
whole scene happening.
You think how quickly they would've found
him and taken him out.
He was just one mile away,
but now they gotta amass this great army.
They gotta go through the whole process.
David has time to get away.
You Think of the network of friendships
that God had given David to hide him and his people.
Even nature itself fought for David
against this great army that was coming against them,
against Absalom himself.
You see, God was multiplying deliverance for David
despite overwhelming odds.
God was for his beloved son.
He was looking at David
and saying, I want you to be the one that reigns.
I want you to be the line through which the Messiah comes.
I need to protect you. And so God is delivering him
through all of these other ways.
Maybe you feel outnumbered right now.
You feel like the enemy is just all over your life attacking
you left and right,
and the enemy is coming at you full strength
and that's what you feel right now.
Don't miss that. David's army was
so much smaller than Absalom's, yet they prevailed.
You remember, uh, back in judges the story of Gideon
where God paired Gideon's army down to just 300 men,
and yet God brought the victory
for Gideon's army against the great hoard
that was coming against them.
It was God. It wasn't the army, it was God.
It wasn't the army. It was nature.
It was God using all these other means to deliver David.
It wasn't the army, it wasn't the strength of the army.
It wasn't the number of the army, it was God himself.
Or maybe, maybe you feel inadequate.
Maybe you feel that you don't measure up.
There's no way God can use me.
There's no way I really deserve anything.
I, I just, I don't measure up.
Do you remember God used a tree branch to do
what the army couldn't do.
Absalom riding through on his mule
and he gets caught up there and,
and God delivers his people from the one who is trying
to take the throne by using a tree.
Listen, if God can use a tree branch, he can use you.
Here's the point. God does not need
optimal conditions to save
you God.
He, he doesn't need,
he creates salvation out of the very means.
The enemy intends to destroy you.
Like Romans 8 28 is not some wishful thinking.
It's true. The settled purpose of God
who works all things including timing, advice,
friendships, nature, God works all things for the glory
of God and the good of those who love him
and are called according to his purpose.
Like that's not, it's not just a pipe dream.
It's not just something we hope happens. It's settled.
I often think of this, you remember what Joseph said?
This is Jacob's son back in Genesis.
Remember what Joseph said to his brothers who had tried
to kill him and then he ended up being like
Pharaoh in all of Egypt.
You remember what Joseph said? This is so powerful.
He said to his brothers, as for you,
you meant evil against me.
But God meant it for good to bring it about
that many people should be kept alive as they are today.
The very thing that they intended to destroy him with.
He said, no, no, no. God actually intended that so
that I'm in my positions to keep you guys alive.
It Was for his very deliverance.
The thing that the enemy intends to destroy us
with is the very thing that God saves us with.
We'll get back to that later,
but just again, God
graciously multiplies deliverance for his people.
He will for you if you're his child,
it might not be on your time schedule, but he delivers you.
He multiplies deliverance
and he will ultimately deliver his children one day forever.
Eternity is sure
that's the one main way he delivers his children.
But day by day, by day, he will work to deliver you
and bring about his glory and your good day after day.
It might not look like you think it should
or what you would want, but it's for your good.
As he delivers his children, just like he did
for David, trust him.
Now the story we left off
with Absalom hanging from his hair in the
tree and he's vulnerable.
What's gonna happen? Well, tragically
what happened next is that Joab, David's military leader,
finds him and puts Javelins through his heart, kills him.
Now the thing about that is
that David had told his armies no one was to touch Absalom.
Yet Joab taking matters into his own hands thinking he was
somehow defending David's honor taking out
this rebel to the throne.
Joab went ahead and killed him.
Anyway, that'll come back a few
chapters later.
But what they did
with Absalom immediately was they buried him in the way
that you were to bury someone who had been killed
by hanging on a tree.
Because they believed at the time that someone
who was hanged on a tree like that was cursed.
It's what it says in the law in Deuteronomy 21.
It says, if a man has committed a crime punishable by death
and he's put to death and you hang him on a tree,
his body shall not remain all night on the tree,
but you shall bury him the same day.
For a hang man is cursed by God.
You shall not defile your land.
The Lord your God is giving you for an inheritance.
So they had to, by virtue of their following the law,
they had to take care of it immediately.
Well, David wasn't close by,
so David couldn't even see his son's body.
They buried it immediately.
And so watch what happens when David finds this out.
He actually got two different stories.
He had to discern which one was true, those kind of things.
But look at the very end of two Samuel 18.
It says verse 33, David finds out about
what happened to Absalom.
They buried his body. He didn't even see him.
All those things. Very end of 18. Look at verse 33.
And the king was deeply moved, went up
to the chamber over the gate and wept.
And as he went, he said, oh my son, Absalom, my son,
my son Absalom,
would I had died instead of you.
Oh, Absalom, my son, my son.
It's tragic, right? The victory was complete.
The rebellion had been squashed.
The kingdom was secure again.
Yet David was still full of grief.
Why? Because the sins
of his past again came full circle.
His adultery, his murder, all of that,
the family dysfunction shows up again.
Nathan's prophecy was again fulfilled in this mess
of of family.
Yet at the same time, God's justice was accomplished.
'cause when Absalom did what he did to David
and to those concubines, he put himself under the judgment
of God, under the justice of God, the curse of God.
And he didn't have the covenant like David had, so
that he was spared.
He was safe. No, it was. It was why the tree was involved.
I believe that because you're like,
why in the world the tree thing, the hair, what?
What is that? Even a part of this?
Because again, Deuteronomy cursed is everyone
who is hanged on a tree cursed.
So what happened to him in the forest was symbolic
of God's view of Absalom.
He was cursed because of all that.
He'd done all the sins he'd committed, he was cursed
and God's judgment was on absalom's wickedness.
Yet even knowing that David was grieved
over the loss of his son,
he cared for Absalom.
He told everybody, don't touch Absalom.
'cause maybe, maybe in the heart of his heart he,
he really thought that Absalom
and he could be reconciled someday,
maybe the Absalom will repent, he'll turn, he'll be,
he'll be right again and we can come back together.
Maybe that's the case. Don't touch him.
David was a loving father in spite
of his rebellion against him as a father.
David loved his son and one of the best for him.
So what is God teaching us with this? Well, a couple things.
First, it's the reminder that circumstances consequences
are painful as a result of sin.
Hasn't that been a constant theme
throughout this whole book?
Sin brings a mess in your life. Sin brings consequences.
Sin brings pain. You reap what you sow right it.
It should cause us to be a little bit apprehensive
about walking into sin.
Just the fact that we see the
consequences of it in our daily lives.
We're forgiven by grace and mercy, but let's avoid sin
because of the pain, the consequence.
So it's again, teaching us that it's reminding us of that.
But there's another lesson here that we need to remember it.
It's that the deliverance God brings in our lives
may not wash away the grief over sins.
Consequences. Like we're gonna face it, we're gonna feel it,
it's gonna be painful, but just the fact
that God delivers us from us doesn't
mean that it won't hurt.
Like Just because you come to Christ
and are saved doesn't mean that life's gonna be just full
of easygoing, fun things.
It will still be painful. Life will still hurt.
We're in the fallen world.
The consequences of your past
or other people's past will still hurt.
And so it won't wash it away necessarily.
It gives you peace in the middle of it, but,
but it won't wash it away.
That's why I believe this is pointing us
forward to something else.
Like we're always looking through the lenses of
how does this point us to redemption?
And so David's grief here over his son,
I believe is pointing us forward
to another father and another son.
See when, when God, the Father in Matthew 13 says,
this is my beloved son, he said
that knowing that that son would die, I,
but different than David not wanting Absalom to die.
This Father God the Father, did allow his son
to die for a purpose.
It's what Romans 8 32 says.
He who did not spare his own son,
but gave him up for us all.
See, here's the point. Looking through the lenses
of redemption here, the whole Bible points us to this.
It's that God mercifully secures eternity through the pain.
God secures eternity through the pain. The cross.
This is this, listen, the cross is God's ultimate reversal.
'cause what looked like defeat in God's justice on sin
became God's eternal victory in his
mercy towards sinners.
What looked like defeat.
As everybody looked there, Jesus is dying on the cross.
This is what's gonna happen. We're all falling apart.
God, in that very moment
when Jesus in his agony cried out, it is finished.
It was that very death
that secured our salvation 'cause.
Listen to what Galatians three says about it.
It says, Christ redeemed us from the curse of the law
by becoming a curse for us.
For it is written cursed is everyone
who is hanged on a tree.
So that curse that Absalom was under that led him
to be hanged on a tree.
The curse that every one of us is under.
Jesus took that curse for us.
He hanged on the tree for us.
It might not rid you of sins consequences in the day to day,
but you can always remember
that your ultimate victory has already been won.
The greater David has defeated the greater enemy, that
that reality, that death itself is swallowed up in victory
through Jesus Christ, our Lord.
That's why you can trust
that when there seems like no way out, God makes a way
when it seems like the enemy's coming at you
or even nature itself is against you, God himself turns all
of that for his glory and for your good.
That's why we can trust him.
He orchestrated every detail for David to be delivered.
He does the same for you and for me.
If we trust him
with everything we are, he works it out.
He's good. So trust him.
Lord, we pray that you help us trust you more today.
That Lord, there is, there is nothing we bring to the table.
This is your victory.
And I pray for those in this room that are struggling
with being overwhelmed, feeling, uh, insecure, un inadequate
or don't measure up or whatever it is.
Or maybe even feeling like, man, yesterday what I did is,
is gonna ruin it forever.
I I've lost my salvation or, or whatever.
God, may we all remember today
that it is your work not ours.
It is your victory, not ours.
It is you who accomplished all that was needed
to be the perfect sacrifice that takes our place on
that tree, that takes the curse that we are under on
that tree that defeats death.
It's swallowed up in victory in Jesus Christ, our Lord.
May we all walk in confidence
and assurance that that's true today, just like it was
for David Living life
that honors you in response day by day
where it looks impossible.
People see our lives and think, how can you have peace
and you can walk in assurance and confidence
because of the victory God delivers us
and we can look with assurance at death and a
and an eternity with confidence
because Jesus defeated death.
What a privilege God it is to be able
to know that those things are true.
Help us Holy Spirit to live that out today.
Maybe somebody in this room has never trusted you with that
and they've tried and they're exhausted, but they want you.
God, I pray that they would just in their hearts
say, Jesus, I'm a sinner.
I need you. I need you to take that place. You did.
I believe it. Come we live it. I'm all you. I'm all yours.
Lord, I pray that you would remind us that we're not alone.
None of us are alone. If we're your child
by faith in Christ, we're not alone any moment of any day.
We won't be alone forever.
We praise you for that soon coming return.
But today we're not alone.
Give us courage in that. In Jesus' name, amen.
Let's stand together and worship. In response.
We.